superlatives time i'll let you go first
well i i mean i gotta start because we
haven't hit this game yet but who day
who day i don't even know that team
because that that was just weird
yesterday and that's the same
it's who dad for the saints who day for
the bangla gotta get you gotta get my
pearls the hell with you okay because i
don't know who they were on the field
yesterday okay that's the problem or who
that was on the field all right either
way it's who's something because the
saints just got you know obliterated
yesterday which was the shocker of the
day i mean of course the atlanta falcons
i mean uh their defense has been pitiful
all year the the saints you know got
drew brees back their o line's been
dominant for the most of the year their
o-line got nominated their defensive
line which you hear me talk about a lot
mike is phenomenal they got pushed
around and got run on yesterday where
the falcons had long drives i think they
had three or four drives with 10 plays
or more that led to points just like you
know again not you know it's the nfl and
i'm never shocked to see a team lose but
that was a surprising loss and it's just
a fashion in which they lost like it was
never a game we never looked at it and
went oh here comes the saints or oh man
that was a bad break for them or that
would have been a game it was just
pretty much a straight up like falcons
kind of controlled it from get-go and it
was a stunner i think one of the biggest
surprises of the year so far and i
understand when you're talking about
teams in the same division you throw out
the records rodney made that point last
night but even with all that yeah the
saints seem to be operating multiple
levels above the falcons and still and
both teams had two weeks to get ready
yep and you got to wonder whether the
saints were maybe living a little too
high on the hog so they were off right
and thinking that this is just an easy
punch here we got the falcons we're
gonna beat them we play him again on
thanksgiving night it's another one all
of a sudden the thanksgiving night game
between the falcons and the saints in
atlanta more intriguing than it would
have been and a lot of pride on the line
yesterday for the falcons i got to give
them credit but with the saints you got
to wonder and it's just it's it's
amazing how quickly the bubble can burst
yeah a team that we think is great all
it takes is one game
and we're like
what's going on here now they have to
re-establish themselves all over again
and i'm gonna flip it around for my
superlative because look and i come up
with a fancy name i guess i could call
it huday award but we know who they are
they are the baltimore ravens who went
in to cincinnati are you stealing my no
i'm not stealing yours yeah i'm going to
call him up with your own stuff okay
bill paulian memorial award although
he's still here
it's the napoleon award okay lamar
jackson is the mvp okay well there's no
doubt lamar jackson's mvp and bill
pauline acknowledged yesterday that that
lamar jackson should be in the mvp
conversation last week he acknowledged
that lamar jackson should not have moved
a receiver yeah lamar jackson defying
the critics on a weekly basis and there
was a true opportunity for a letdown
yesterday for the ravens they had beaten
the seahawks by 14. they had beaten the
patriots by 17. this was the one soft
spot on the schedule before things get
very difficult over the next month they
went into cincinnati and they took care
of businesses why i firmly believe
they'd cover the nine and a half point
spread because ron harbaugh was not
going to let this team have a letdown
and lamar jackson
if you're watching all again
with the sunglasses he does not care
who the opponent is he doesn't care if
it's a game they're supposed to win he
doesn't care if it's a game they're
supposed to lose he just goes out and
plays each and every week and that
47-yard touchdown that we saw with that
spin move incredible he is the mvp right
now it's his got a long way to go yeah
things can change but i like what i'm
seeing from the ravens five straight
wins and off we go i mean he's the
leader in the clubhouse right now i
think yeah i mean we'll see what russell
wilson does tonight against the 49ers
and desean watson of course didn't play
but yeah lamar jackson is he is he's the
leader with these two games back to back
and you know i know you and i talked
about this we we thought that maybe the
patriots game instead of being like a oh
they're going to fall asleep with the
wheel was going to be more of like a
launching point for the ravens where
they're going to go
we're good we're for real like well we
thought we were for real but now we know
it since we did that to the patriots and
i think we saw that yesterday next four
real quick yeah they have the texans at
home at the rams yeah 49ers at home and
at the bills yeah so that's a tough test
right there they're playing some good
defenses that will certainly be uh
equipped to stop that run game or at
least slow it down and give it a
challenge all right um
blunderville in nashville okay
blunderville and nashville holy cow
kansas city chiefs can we line up and
kick a field goal no we can't and we've
screwed that up twice okay i mean uh i
don't know what to say here to be a
superlative okay i said blunderville
negative well yeah okay well you're so
negative you're so hated yeah yeah yeah
they won the award for stinking at the
end of the game okay there you go but
yeah i just look at that and of course
you know i should give derek henry a lot
of credit you're right he was awesome
ryan tannehill great in the clutch
moments uh but again i do look at the
kansas city chiefs you had a five-point
lead and you were lining up to kick a
field goal with under two minutes left
in the game i mean you're in there okay
so it's a snap where i don't know if the
center snapped it too early or if the
holder gave a false signal either way
they messed that up the nashville and
tennessee titans go down score a
touchdown they take the lead here comes
kansas city and mahomes they line up
again guy comes off the edge
times out the snap perfectly i mean to
where he blocks it here's the blunder if
you're watching on tv the first one
where this the holder was not ready and
now tana hill has a great drive and this
is where tannen hill has just been
better than marcus mariota just a little
bit better better feel as an overall
quarterback you know his he runs when
appropriate and then his throwing
is pretty top-notch he is not afraid to
pull the trigger into some tight windows
but ultimately it's just kansas city
finding a way to screw the game up i
think more than anything and there's a
few moments in the game too where you
know kansas city was up 10 nothing early
and this is i thought one of the
underrated moments where 10-0 they're
kind of driving again and mahomes has
sammy watkins over the middle on a third
down he is wide open and overthrows it
and they end up having to punt because
they were on like kind of field gold
fringe territory and that was a moment
where i thought oh they could have
really controlled the game and put
tennessee in a tough spot didn't happen
and even at the end of the game
you know they had another timeout i
would have liked to see them take one
more shot down the middle to get a chunk
piece of yards
maybe it doesn't matter i mean they
don't block the guy off the edge either
way but that was a that's gonna be a
tough loss for the chiefs to swallow
this morning all right well if if you
are going to go negative while couching
it as a positive i'm going to do the
same thing yeah i'm going to give out
the willie mays on the mets award to
adam vinatieri because as much as i hate
to say it and he's a hall of famer he
should be a first ballot hall of famer
which has never happened for a kicker
and and and it's probably going to be
hard for him to get there and you have
to wonder shereen williams who's one of
the hall of fame voters made the
observation before the season started
that eli manning was actually hurting
his hall of fame case by hanging on and
adding
negative performances to what otherwise
would be a potential hall of fame career
at some point that specter arises also
for adam vinatieri i still think he's a
long way to go before that happens but
this last year is tarnishing his name
it's tarnishing his legacy and a certain
point i know it's not easy to do and
it's easy for me to say it there's a
point where you just have to step aside
he thought about doing it after the
first couple of weeks of the season the
colts wanted him to stay around for
leadership purposes then after that he
started to get it together again the
past couple of weeks inexcusable a
couple of losses that could have been
wins you cannot have that if it was
anybody else
you take the na and they do that at
every other position in football they
take the name off the jersey and they
evaluate and they need to take the name
off the jersey and evaluate there are
plenty of guys out there who can kick
adam vinatieri's not getting it done and
somebody needs to intervene and say adam
you just you just it's time yeah yeah
it's time and and look he's a hall of
famer yeah some of the greatest kicks of
all time when rodney harrison who was a
teammate of adam vinitare's with the
patriots says i no longer trust adam
vinatieri that's what got my attention
because rodney's got every reason to be
biased and continue to support him i
hear you and and look a great leader
transcends the kicker position etc but
it's it's time yeah it's just no that
was uh it's tough to watch you're right
he's a legend he he is he's a hall of
famer he can't he really can't even
screw it up at this point unless he
plays for like two more years of like
this kind of type of play but uh yeah
that was just a disappointing
performance all together by the colts
hoyer wasn't good uh the you know the
the dolphins kind of just fighting
hanging around in football games and
yeah they outplayed they all played the
indianapolis colts there's there's no
other way to say it um
i'm gonna give just like good for these
guys okay the cleveland browns i mean i
don't even know what my superlatives is
they're just going to say i'm happy for
them all right happy for cleveland i
don't believe it keep trying you'll
eventually come up with i was going to
come up with something keep talking for
those when they told me we had one more
one more a little more time to do
another superlative i couldn't really
think of what i wanted to say about
cleveland how does that make it
different than any other surprise well
my other ones i was good you copied my
first one you liked it so much i said
who day and you used it for yours so
shut up florio okay what do you want to
say about the browns but uh you answered
the bell a little yesterday i mean found
a way to win a tough football game baker
mayfield's been dealing with a lot of
criticism and he drives them down late
in the game and has a number of great
throws we saw the jarvis landry he makes
a great catch but then you know
game-winning touchdown that's a big
moment for a young team so
you know i i guess i should say it's
like to get off my back get off my back
award at least for four days until we
play again on thursday night and they
got a deal but happy for cleveland will
do i like that on the graphic there all
right you're very good
you know the way you were holding that
microphone a little bit ago i thought
you were sending me a message yeah like
watch that watch that second finger yeah
yeah
stop it stop it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports